[Musique]
bonjour joseph virassamy bonjour vous
êtes le des onze candidats aux
sénatoriales du 24 septembre martinique
candidat divers gauche dirions-nous mais
est-ce bien important finalement car
manifestement ces sénatoriales pour vous
joseph virassamy sont surtout un forum
dans votre lutte incessante contre la
collectivité territoriale de martinique
eh bien vous avez parfaitement du ca
vous savez qu'il y à 2 2 postes à
pourvoir
en réalité il y à un poste de sénateur
et il y à un poste pour que la clé
grands électeurs votent une motion de
défiance à l'égard de la collecte c'est
ce qu'ils ont fait à marier c'est ce que
c'est marie c'est ce que je leur dis et
je souhaite qu'il fasse preuve de
civisme à l'égard de la population
martiniquaise et ne pas me laisser tout
seul depuis huit ans à me battre contre
les sept collectivités territoriales qui
est complètement illégal êtes un peu
hors sujet au risque de jeter le trouble
sur l'importance de ce scrutin
je vais vous dire je crois pas du tout
que je sors sujet d'ailleurs les les
conseils municipaux que j'ai déjà vu ne
le crois pas du tout d'abord j'ai un
parent en pointe où je leur montre doyen
train précise que ce jeudi et je dis que
la collectivité territoriale est
illégale et que si on fait une
sénatoriale dans un contexte juridique
et institutionnel illégal sénatoriales
risque d'être annulé ça ne jette pas un
trouble auprès de ces grands électeurs
auprès de la population par ricochet de
profiter d'un tel aucune de telles
occasions pour aborder tel ou tel sujet
eh bien je vais vous dire quelque chose
c'est que la ctm avec la disparition
d'une des deux collectivités nous fait
perdre 300 millions d'euros et que le
fait qu'elle ne soit plus on ne soit
plus rup région ultrapériphérique nous
fait perdre encore 200 millions d'euros
ça fait 500 millions d'euros que l'on
que l'on perde par le fait qu'on ait
perdu le département et la région
et comme ça devenait collectivités
territoriales alors vous voyez bien que
le sénateur qui est
le sénateur le parlementaire des
collectivités territoriales doit se
préoccuper de ces 500 millions d'euros
nous en avons besoin c'est 500 millions
d'euros dans toutes les communes de
martinique
josé virassamy est ce que vous êtes sûr
vous êtes un obstiné un opiniâtre est
têtue vous êtes le idée fixe de la
politique martiniquaise je ne suis pas
l'idée fixe de la politique
martiniquaise moi je souhaite simplement
que l'on respecte cette population on
l'a trompée en 2010 avec un scrutin qui
est complètement à côté des procédures
normales qui sont prévues dans la
constitution le la commission européenne
vient au mois de juin d'accepter de
recevoir et à déclarer recevables les
requêtes que j'ai fait mais si vous avez
un niveau de la commission européenne
c'est parce qu'au niveau français
toutes vos demandes de vos doléances ou
de vos requêtes n'ont pas été bien
suffit de voir pour vous vous avez
parfaitement compris
il se trouve que le législateur n'a pas
prévu que le conseil d'état ou la cour
de cassation qui sont les derniers
filtre avant de faire passer une
question prioritaire de
constitutionnalité au conseil
constitutionnel sont complètement est
complètement impliqué dans cette affaire
là le conseil d'état fait trois faux et
usage de faux dans cette affaire et
c'est un crime est une escroquerie
d'après le conte l'heure il n'y allait
pas fort l'alsace dans le faux et usage
de faux par personne détenteur de
l'autorité publique ça s'appelle un
crime est une escroquerie c'est le code
pénal qui le dit l'article 441 6 313
alors le conseil d'état serait alors
dans ce cas la juge et partie et c'est
pas étonnant qu'il ait bloqué la plupart
des qpc que j'ai fait de laisser aux
questions prioritaires de
constitutionnalité qui s'adresse aux
comptes au conseil constitutionnel alors
vous vous référez beaucoup à 7,7
pl est ce que vous avez déposé auprès de
la commission européenne vous avez une
réponse au début du mois de juin le 8
juin disant que l'attribution de numéros
officielle à votre plainte n'implique
pas nécessairement qu'une procédure
d'infraction sera engagée par la
commission ce qui n'empêche pas de cris
déjà victoire et bien je vais vous dire
pourquoi c'est parce que il les
infractions sont tels que on est sûr que
la 7ème va être annulé regardez le 24
janvier rappelé 80e vous dites ça oui
oui oui je sais que vous allez me le
dire mais nous sommes arrivés au niveau
au niveau international donc il fallait
auparavant avoir fait les toutous le
chemin à l'intérieur de l'état c'est
comme ça dans ta notamment vont saisir
la drogue c'est un complot franco
français que vous portez sur la scène
internationale et ben oui exactement
c'est un complot oui oui c'est
complètement un complot parce que on a
voulu la préparation c'est quelque chose
d'un monstre qu'on a fait surgir de
terre mais ça sert quels pourraient être
tous et tout ça si vous voulez si vous
voulez la ctm d'ailleurs là la façon
dont elles marchent c'est un véritable
cauchemar et les martiniquais lorsque
l'accident m sera annulée vont se rendre
compte qu'ils qu'ils ont vécu là ces
thèmes comme la russie qui y voit un oui
oui c'est un cauchemar
et puis je vais vous dire pourquoi
c'était un méta nul va être annulée
parce qu'il y avait la violation le 24
janvier on a expulsé les partisans du
non qui pourtant avec 33% des résultats
et l'expulsion à janvier le 24 janvier
2010 risque de huit districts exclure
les partisans du non d'une consultation
comme ça référendaire c'est violer la
directive 2000 12 juillet 2000 qui a été
voté alors vous savez ce que c'est que
ce que supprimer une queue violé une
directive européenne
ça veut dire que là c'était mal est
morte quoi ça veut dire ça et puis c'est
votre interprétation des faits mais non
c'est pas une interprétation
c'est comme ça que c'est exactement ça
lorsqu'on et puis en plus il ya le droit
électoral et référendaire européens qui
devront donner 50 50 au des moyens
publics
oui oh non ça on a violé aussi ce droit
électoral avait été discriminés parce
que porteur d'une
exactement voilà et ça vaut annulation
de la ctm et puis l autre chose le il ya
une procédure logique normale qui est de
poser une question et une consultation
sur une proposition du gouvernement
on a fait deux questions de consultation
sur une proposition du président de la
république eh bien ça veut dire qu'on a
violé le principe de sécurité juridique
qui est à la base du droit européen
safer de l'osm au lancement on abandonne
et qu'on viole le droit européen
et bien c'est mort après quoi donc il
suffira que la cndh penche dessus et
puis cette fameuse qpc qui n'a peuple
qui n'a pas pu aller jusqu'au bout
l'italie a déjà été condamné pour cette
affaire la romandie monsieur viol temps
là c'était un mail est morte et les
sénatoriales vont se dérouler dans un
contexte illégal c'est pour ça que vous
demandez aux grands électeurs de de
remplir un bulletin que vous leur tende
et concernant non je leur demande
simplement de voter une motion de
défiance c'est à dire qu'il qu'il dise
avec moi pourquoi il le ferait
aujourd'hui pourrait le faire parce que
j'ai bien compris je regarde les
conseillers municipaux dans ce que je
lis lorsque je les rencontre mais ils
applaudissent il y en a même qui me
disent monsieur vous auriez dû ce que
vous êtes en train de nous dire avec vos
paroles pointent et vous aurais dû le
dire à toute la population et c'est ce
que je suis en train de faire ils
applaudissent aujourd'hui parce qu'ils
comprennent aujourd'hui oui voilà parce
que il y a un tableau
diaporama avec des explications et c'est
pas très compliqué l'endroit
impressionnant à l'article il ya des
trois articles pas surpris qu ils
comprennent aussi tardivement mais moi
je suis un peu surpris mais à vrai dire
il ya une telle omerta sur ce que je
raconte depuis quelques années être les
guides du peuple mais revoit ses élus
ils vont le manifester le 24 janvier
j'espère que cette motion de défiance
ils vont la voter parce que je vous
répète pour moi il n'y a que seul mandat
de sénateur en jeu
l'autre poste et fin pour pouvoir faire
voter les grands électeurs
cette motion de défiance et j'espère que
ce sera voté à 90 99 % pour que pour que
la justice française comprennent que
l'état français comprennent et que la
commission européenne et la cour de
justice sur de l'union européenne
comprenne que les martiniquais sont
derrière moi pour pouvoir faire
condamner cela faire revenir le 500
millions d'euros faire revenir le droit
commun ici et que les marchés ne
tiennent jamais de josé virassamy vous
avez rencontré toutes les toutes les
sphères de la justice au niveau français
qu'est-ce qu'il vous dise eh bien vous
savez le procureur de la république ici
ne veut pas poursuivre le conseil d'état
le juge d'instruction en vision dans
l'article 85 ne veut pas poursuivre le
conseil d'état la cour d'appel lorsque
c'est le haut de la pyramide mais oui
c'est le haut de la pyramide l'accord le
président de la cour d'appel m'a dit la
chose suivante monsieur votre quête
votre appel il
il est irrecevable on veut pas vous dire
pourquoi
et puis un mois disent ah oui nous a dit
ça il m'a dit ça à moi et je le dis
devant sept ans dans cette antenne et il
me dit monsieur il me rappelle pour me
dire ça monsieur
cette affaire est très grave parce
qu'elle peut amener le conseil d'état
devant une cour d'assises si le
président de la cour d'appel vous dit
que les frégates pour une pièce pour
cour d'assises ça veut dire qu'il l'a le
dossier en main il a montré il a fait
qu'il est l'un des dossiers qui ne vous
a jamais dit ça il peut alors attendez
le coup de fil mais ce serait donnée qui
vous le dise
de toute façon j'ai fait un compte rendu
je l' ai déjà envoyé partout y compris à
la commission européenne
ai je demandé que le conseil d'état soit
poursuivie au niveau de la de la justice
pénale internationale joseph virassamy
l'homme qui peut faire tomber le conseil
d'état je ne sais pas si le conseil
d'état va tomber mais il ya eu un vide
juridique qui montrent que la cour de
cassation et le conseil d'état qui sont
les derniers stades pour pompes pour
dire si on en voit aussi on n'en voit
pas une qpc vers le conseil
constitutionnel est fautif dans cette
affaire-là
et on ne peut pas être juge et partie
alors il faudra voir comment l'état
français se débrouillent avec cette
affaire-là
en tout cas c'est une espèce de bombes
liquides en aidant les pattes si je puis
dire de la justice française derrière ce
dossier là est ce que vous avez vraiment
envie d'être sénateur
mais bien sûr que je voudrais bien être
sénateur comme comme pas mal de gens
parce qu'être sénateurs c'est c'est
avoir les moyens plutôt qu'être simples
citoyens de mener en plus ce combat là
moi ce que je veux vous dire aussi c'est
que les martiniquais me donnons les
moyens parce que vous voyez bien que si
on annule la ctm il y aura des
sénatoriales il y aura des cantonales en
2018 il va y avoir des régionales en
2010 il ailleurs des municipales en 2020
je m'adresse aujourd'hui la population
pour leur dire
rappelez vous bien cela je vais avoir à
vous à vous à vous interroger à vous
demander de soutenir les gens qui
meurent on a mené le raid
merci d'avoir été ce matin avec nos jeux
vous à venir à ça me rappelle que vous
êtes l'un des onze candidats en lice
pour les sénatoriales du 24 septembre
c'est d'avoir été danseur crédit bonne
journée merci beaucoup
[Musique]
décrétée